thanks so much Alan Fisher Alan fiser
there thanks for that update on a very
fluid situation talking about fluid
situations while we've been on air some
pictures have come in we want to show
them to you now this these are live
pictures coming in from a shifer
hospital in Gaza where there's just been
an Israeli strike at the gate just in
front of that hospital well this comes
just hours after we heard from the head
of the health Ministry in Gaza that only
four Hospitals now four hospitals are
actually still functioning in the Gaza
Strip let's talk to yumna stage she
joins us now on the phone from Gaza City
so yumna let's start with the very
latest this strike on a shiffer hospital
tell us about what that has
done yes Sav so that was a drone uh mile
that was uh hit on the front gate of
shifa Hospital of course there are
casualties from that strike between
killed and injured we still don't know
the exact figure since the attack has
just happened let's note that the shifa
hospital has over 5,000 patients of the
injuries in that complex and T tens of
thousands of uh displaced people in the
Fret yards and the backyard of aifa
complex aifa is the largest hospital in
Gaza City an the Goda strip but this is
not the only attack the ambulances that
have been uh uh taking injuries now and
heading to the ra Crossing in a press
conference a shifa hospital was just
saying that they want uh they they
demand International protection for
these ambulances as they have been T
being targeted on Rashid Street the past
days and they were asking on air the the
Red Cross to escort these ambulances on
their trip to the raah crossing that's
when an ambulance also got hit from
those groups now we still don't have any
news about the ambulances that got
targeted in that group of ambulances
that were heading towards ra we know
this from local sources at aifa hospital
itself after just after the Striking of
the front gate of
shiffer yumna in addition to the strike
on shiffer Hospital in addition to the
strike you mentioned on
ambulances there was also very Grim
pictures circulating showing the
aftermath of an Israeli strike on a
civilian Convoy we understand heading
from the north towards the South where
Israel had told people to go can you
tell us what we know about that strike
on the AL Rashid Road and we should let
me just warn viewers these pictures you
might find distressing so they they're
quite difficult pictures to watch but
this this is the aftermath civilians and
civilian Goods strewn all over a
road we're playing those pictures now
yum now I know you're in Gaza City I can
only imagine the sort of life and death
decisions civilians like you have to
make about
is it safer to stay in Gaza City where
the Israeli Army has told people to get
out or is it actually more dangerous to
do what these civilians apparently tried
to do which is get out of the North and
head to the
South well actually these civilians are
heading to the South according to the
Israeli Army's uh constant orders and uh
lifl lets that it's it it keeps on
throwing on the civilians and and even
calls that it keeps on making on these
civilians homed and and and phones to
tell them to instantly evacuate and the
time is running out from them so they
are taking the risk uh to evacuate to
the South but all through the past days
four days now in a row we have seen
targeting on a Rashid Street although
the Israeli tanks are not on a Rashid
Street there are they are on salahadin
street but uh cars and uh uh cars and
convoys of civilians that are heading
towards the South are being targeted by
tank shells uh from salahadin Street and
air strikes at the same time now at
least even before that at least uh eight
children have then uh killed today in
the Convoy of the civilian cars that
were taken or that were taking their way
to the South most of the people who have
been killed in this targeting are with
women and children and until now the
medical sources have told us that three
men at least have been killed while
dozens have been injured in that attack
on the civilian cars heading
south all right yum who continues to
report to us from inside Gaza City now
surrounded by Israeli forces we thank
you for your updating us and reporting
to us on the situation there in the
North of